[Music]
in Athens it's a victory for the face of
the old guard kiriakos Mitsotakis is a
former Prime Minister's son and he heads
the center-right New Democracy party a
decades-long political mainstay now he's
vowing to renew Greece with a
pro-business agenda by slashing taxes
attracting investment and taming
bureaucracy I want a strong Greece with
self-confidence that will claim the
place in Europe it deserves and not be a
beggar or an object of pity but
Mitsotakis list of challenges at home is
long and by now familiar Greece's 18
percent unemployment rate is the euro
zone's highest and Greece remains under
tough budget targets from its creditors
even after exiting its bailout programs
outgoing Prime Minister Alexis tsipras
swept to power promising to stand up to
those creditors but his popularity
declined as he caved to their demands
and imposed painful reforms demands
large and difficult circle is drawing to
a close we are now going to evaluate
soberly what was right as well as the
mistakes we made as always I will not
refuse to accept my own responsibilities
in this one alone
Sunday's results dealt blows both to
suppresses left-wing syriza party and to
the extreme right Golden Dawn it didn't
clear the hurdle to re-enter Parliament
as Greece continues to seek a path out
of economic turmoil voters have handed a
win to the traditional mainstream news
Matters has been covering the elections
in Greece for us and he joins me now
from Athens welcome your big changes in
Athens the whole political gravity seems
to be shifting to the center House had
gone down in the Greek capital
here in the heart of Athens on the main
square just outside Parliament I could
hardly see any excitement neither today
nor throughout the election night
yesterday and over this sea change in in
Greek politics and that's very different
from the time when Alexis tsipras took
power where people were really excited
where hopes were high it is just that
resignation with Greek voters runs
really deep after four tough years four
tough years of austerity they had to
endure you seen that this is now the
first post bailout government for Greece
Mitsotakis is making big promises tax
cuts more jobs or how much leeway does
he have to do things differently a to
challenges Mitsotakis really faces one
is of course he will have to honor the
terms and conditions for the latest
bailout package by the made by
international and by European creditors
and he said he will honor that this
agreement while at the same time yes
promised as you have said a Greek voters
big tax cuts more jobs something that
particularly the young people in Greece
really hope for I went and with my
colleague Barbara Basel to an island
just off the coast coast of Athens Agena
which is just a short ferry ride really
to see what voters make of their new
government fishing around Agena an
island just off the coast of athens
Stelio Slava Dario's runs the boat with
his father he's the third generation of
his family to make his living on the
water today he's taken his friend jurgis
Pepa's along for company
we had lot of people on the sea but Jobs
was fishing or on the sea and now nobody
at my age or a little bit more bigger
they don't stay it's not very good
because we have Islands the lot of
tourists come to see our islands and
what in ten years where nobody will be
on the fishing what they will they come
to see stelios hopes tourism will save
his family's business around 30,000
small fishermen like him are fighting
for survival in the face of declining
stocks and hard economic times his
friend jurgis wants the new government
to deliver change quickly
after years of tax increases and cuts in
public spending I think that tax
payments are not fair with us it's more
fair to the rich people than to the
media or to the lower-class people I am
expecting this as well from the new
government many in Aegina hope the new
government will cut taxes especially the
widely unpopular real estate tax the
incoming Prime Minister Mitsotakis also
wants to attract more investment and
create jobs promises that Viki Paris
Kabul has heard over and over again
she's been looking for work for years
today she's praying for a miracle from a
geena's patron saint she hopes he will
help hiria cause Mitsotakis to finally
print change everybody promise this is
the politicals they promised but now
things are very difficult he has to do
it if you will not do what he's gonna he
promised he will have very big problem
from the from the people is we are not
like before we are not like before we
don't forgive
setting a course for economic recovery
many believe the new government has just
one chance to get it right half a
million young Greeks have already left
the country due to the economic crisis
but that's something these two friends
don't want to do they plan to stay on
and fight for a better future
so job as we saw in your report high
expectations of the incoming government
but what does this election defeat mean
for the outgoing government of Alexis
tsipras he came with such high hopes in
2015 with his tiny little Selita party
why was he punished by the voters local
Rita from a European perspective Alexis
tsipras has really shifted from a
radical far left politician to an
acknowledged and recognized the
center-left statesman and that is for
two reasons he sauce through the
economic reforms where he set out to
abolish when he started his campaign and
began becoming prime minister in Greece
so really moving from an
anti-establishment anti austerity
government to one that embraced those
reforms and that did lead Greece back on
a path of economic recovery but just not
enough for voters so so to appreciate
that change and then also he made some
domestic decisions settling a named
route with the neighboring North
Macedonia something that didn't go down
with nationalists oh well
didn't go down well at all with with
nationalists in Greece many people
criticized him for this so changes he
made that made him recognize in Europe
but many people in Greece are therefore
critical of him and finally go another
interesting aspect of this election is
that the Golden Dawn which is a
far-right party has been kicked out of
Parliament did that come as a surprise
not exactly because the party has legal
problems here in Greece and that that is
that's been challenging here throughout
the past couple of of years and also
there is a new right-wing party that has
sit-ins off those those voices
so really you what and also also overall
you haven't changed back towards
traditional more mainstream parties
parties in Greece or
that explains why the golden dawn is no
longer in Parliament we had God much is
covering the Greek elections for us
thank you very much for that update from
Athens